Cleveland and Columbus Ohio I'm coming
through May 31st June 1st the bum ass
cities tour is going to the
quintessential bum-ass cities Cleveland
you ain't got to do I never heard a
good thing about you in my life Lake
Erie is that Cleveland that even sounds
terrible what kind of a name for a lake
is that Columbus Ohio you got OSU and
that's it nothing else going on there
summer there's no basketball there's no
football if you're not in scoring OSU
you've got nothing else to do and if you
are a school at OSU you're probably
stupid so you need to come to my show
maybe just my Indians will rub off on
you get you an eight get your tickets at
option.com now